hey guys ferry here at tip with another
review for you this one is for Jonah
Hill's directorial debut it is mid 90s
and it's one heck of a territorial debut
it's actually been really exciting at
the festival right now between this and
the star is born
we're just getting to see some really
talented actors step behind the lens and
they're delivering great highly creative
work this movie in particular is just
oozing with style and it's so abundantly
clear that this is a story and a group
of characters that Jonah Hill was just
super passionate about he knew exactly
how we wanted to capture it one of the
smartest decisions he makes right off
the bat is shooting on sixteen
millimeter and going with the 4:3 aspect
ratio because movie takes place in the
mid 90s and it instantly gives you that
kind of feeling and it sucks you into
this world because it's kind of got this
this whole video quality to it and it
works so well right off the bat and then
it sucks you in and never lets you go
and the same goes for the group of
characters here the story here isn't
very it's not very plot heavy period
there isn't a traditional beginning
middle and end it's more of us slice of
life live with these characters kind of
experience and the characters is such a
strong charismatic group with so much
chemistry with each other that that
works exceptionally well at the center
of this we have Sonny Soulja who you
might know from the killing of a sacred
deer
he plays Stevie here and he's a really
young kid I think he's 13 and he's kind
of just looking for someone to connect
to in his life and that is definitely
not his older brother played by Lucas
hedges and it's actually a really
interesting role for Lucas hedges
because I personally haven't seen him in
anything where he's kind of a really
vicious bully but he plays that
character really well but Stevie winds
up gravitating towards this group of
older skater kids so they're they're in
their late teens whereas he's really
young and he kind of gets absorbed into
their group and they treat him like a
little brother and they show him all the
things that they're into which include
skateboarding and the skateboarding in
this movie is
absolutely astounding the way he
captures it it it does really glorify
that community in a way where I was kind
of in all of their ability the entire
time but with Stevie in these older kids
and what they're into it can make the
movie a little difficult to watch at
some points or maybe even going as far
as saying unpleasant because these are
kids who are into you know they're
they're into girls and they're into
drugs and drinking and Stevie is just so
so young and he's being exposed to that
that ya can make it a little difficult
to watch and digest but the point is
Jonah Hillel does such a good job
convincing you that this is his honest
reality so because he achieves that I
have absolutely no problem with it
and he also makes a brilliant decision
to go with other actors who are not
professional actors and they're all
exceptional but I did want to give one
shout out and I want to get his name
right here nikhyl Smith I hope I
pronounced that correctly he's basically
the leader of this group of kids that
stevie winds up becoming a part of and
he just has such warmth to him and it's
so appealing and his chemistry with
stevie is really a remarkable aspect of
the film here and you know what so is
the score to this movie is just brimming
with so much life across the board but
then we've got this score here that was
done by Trent Reznor and Atticus Ross
and it just hits the perfect beats at
just the right time and it gives the
movie so much
energy and even more style and flavor
than it already has so all of these
things just come together in a way that
proved to me at least that Jonah Hill
went into this project as a director who
knew every single element exactly what
he wanted to achieve and all of the
pieces aligned exceptionally well and
what we wind up with is a movie set in
the mid 90s about a group of really
charismatic kids that just suck you in
and they make you want to spend time
with them so I'm gonna go ahead and give
mid-90s an a-minus I really enjoyed this
film I enjoyed being sucked into it and
I really appreciated the honesty that
Jonah Hill achieves in it too so there
you go my review of mid 90s if you're
looking forward to seeing the movie hit
that comment section below share some
thoughts right there
and as always be sure to keep an eye on
both Collider quick and also the main
clutter video YouTube channel because
we're gonna have more tip coverage
coming your way real soon
[Music]